ah oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
l'information
[Musique]
pour monter
je ne connais pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je
au bout d'un moment
commandée depuis d'entre nous
non millions
[Musique]
la voiture est toujours
vous l'avez entendu
ces duels
non
l'allongement qui est pour
nous en sortir
bush
camus ok
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette pression
je conviens
deux conteurs
pelli devant ce soir coûtant choisi
avait alors fermé
là
aurore
coc
le pharmacien nouveau présent
le premier rang
nous verrons bien
[Musique]
par k o
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chantonnay
non
[Musique]
le ton
bien
nous sommes touchés
je re
des rumeurs courent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'il ait rien sur les mots
j'en veux
les émissions
[Musique]
pour eux aussi
pour avancer
[Musique]
non
nous
l'histoire
donc
touche à tout cela
nous touchons tous soit
tous
[Musique]
pour ça
et
oh
oh oui
pour le
on aime tant
je ne
tous
oh
le soir
nous
à
toi
tous
l'histoire
nous
non
[Musique]
avec nous
demont
je suis
[Musique]
où
dès mon travail
[Musique]
voir
il va
[Musique]
tous
au choix je couche
richesse par sa bouche en a plus
bois ou plus vous faites
au perdant
tous
à temps
oui
et
le témoin
m
et toi tu as
bonjour
[Musique]
je le sais bien
on s'est montrés
douze fois
tout ça
e
soit
nous
pourquoi
tous
quoique
où
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
où
non
[Applaudissements]
je
oh
[Musique]
les son nom
jours
la famille
oh non
[Musique]
je suis en quarts
je suis là
je suis
rochette vouloir cacher
[Musique]
eh oui
c'est tout ce que
[Musique]
pourquoi
ces circuits
oh
je
à
que vous
et
[Musique]
au revoir à
le voici
mon ami
[Musique]
tout ça
le choix
[Musique]
jeudi
si vos
je
[Musique]
oh
g
il y
ça brûle
[Musique]
m
je voudrais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
non
tout cela
voir
toutefois
non
[Applaudissements]
le
il a vu
non
tout cela le mouvement
[Applaudissements]
le projet
thomas
[Musique]
encore une fois merci
vraiment
m
[Applaudissements]
chez lui
[Musique]
il est
voir des pierres et l'expérience des
jeunes
gk
cette histoire de même aux gens
[Musique]
l'analyse de l'existant dans ses côtés
et quand cela sent exister c'est au tour
l'autre
jour de grand vent me porte et son
soutien
réveille des émotions a été prise pour
fasciner
aujourd'hui pourquoi
non
le site et que vaut vraiment le voir
je crois
pour moi les autres membres
pour les petits
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pb
il y avait des c
il faut aussi laisser faire
non
comment
expérimentation
cheyrou
[Musique]
des gens de rêver
le poids augmente ses ventes
[Musique]
pour moi ce que je veux
et pour aller vous
ce projet
[Musique]
depuis
je
c'est le professeur pendant ces décrets
de formation où ce travail on lèche
libye jusqu'à la main quelques petits
mots
[Musique]
je mon but c'est elle qui le dit
comme je sais que nous
il nous sommes entre les mains de dieu
j'en ai vu et vécu plusieurs fois dans
mon insistance tisci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
les amis du pays pour mieux le jeune
nous allons accueillir maintenant à
grands défenseurs il a dit que vous
connaissez bien qui était son avis qui
se bat depuis des années on la connait
bien ta gueule et vitupère
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ou pas
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi cette manie sans déconner 22
ans lavilliers il est sur vos choix
rationnel
[Musique]
alors moi je me suis souvent posé la
question ça veut dire quoi il produit
parce que tout le monde et pour la vie
j'étais pas très à l'aise avec dédier
cette appellation là et en fait j'ai
compris bien tard que être pro vie en
fait c'est vouloir faire progresser la
vie des autres c'est un peu comme la
sainte et finalement c'est vouloir
servir les autres dans leur vie même les
villes et plus fragiles et vouloir
écrire passé avant soi et ça finalement
quand j'ai rencontré pierre le jeune
c'était la seule chose que j'ai appris
d'elle plutôt que j'attendais des
histoires croquante un peu sur son passé
de militante etc et j'ai vu
s'intéressent surtout s'intéresser
surtout à moi et je me suis dit voilà
c'est ça une vraie pro vie quoi
et donc je l'écris petite chanson après
je vous rassure y aura des trucs assez
joyeux parce qu'elle est aussi elle met
un peu les moulante et donc voilà après
on vous proposera chanter avec nous
[Musique]
e
tu pas sans faire de bruit comme il en
est de ta vie tu laisse sur le carreau
des enfants des amis
[Musique]
tu vas nous manquer
non mais
tu vas
m
tu peux poser sans re
le fardeau de ton mari
temps on allait en fait tu ne l'as
jamais trahir
tu vas 2
reposez vous m'avez
[Musique]
du lot
posée
de penser que la déplier
de prison pour te faire une fête sans
pareil quittait ce qui vaut j'ai le
coeur si chaud et j'adresse un merci au
ciel
[Musique]
pardon d'être assis peu ce jour des
funérailles mais
où seront de ceux qui en longeur
tvo tonnes
[Musique]
on va continuer
continue
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci de voir exister aucun autre nom
qui va grands
ce qui peur que qui tombe
on est un athée mais mamés
en
temarii
de penser que la
des milliers de prises
petit test qui vivent chez le coeur
un show et 4 et 5 mai
merci au ciel
c'est que la roue des piliers de prison
pour te faire une fête sans fin
ty eskimos j'ai le coeur si chaud et
j'adresse un insigne au ciel
merci merci mamie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tactique qui me gêne le plus ancien est
devant
[Musique]
alors aussi les pro vie pour moi c'est
emmerder les gens les oiseaux de
mauvaises augures tous ceux qui veulent
préparer le monde a dû s'occuper du
monde maintenant c'est tous les
progressiste qui veulent nous dire
qu'avec leurs techniques on viendra plus
heureux alors tellement bien fait que le
mil et leurs effets pour faire l'amour
qu'il est fait pour faire des enfants
naturellement c'est naturellement
supporter le temps qui passe et la
technique est à son service comme
l'argent faut le rappeler à tous les
puissants qui nous dirigent
le but c'est vivre c'est pas survivre
voilà vous proposez chanter il ferait
sans fond de jeu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce matin
comment
oui
tous
coc
quatre endroits
c'est quoi
j'avais silencieux
c'est pourtant du coup
ce sens
super
mais quoi
à
[Musique]
et vivent toujours
sans discours
sur les armes
inutile vous avez fait ce qui était le
mieux
honfleur
blanc
qui sait
autant
donc
on
on a ça
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ap
à
[Applaudissements]
sortir du silence en pensant aux
souffrances de nos mères et se dire que
nous nous rendons pas heureux
dans la cour
bah
oula
non
quand
et
on
ap
pourtant l'on proposé de chanter des jo
c'est sur le petit ma philosophie d'amel
bent fois vous connaissez tous les temps
parfois les parents à bouger un peu les
paroles sont projetées des paroles super
c'est quoi voilà on voulait sortais je
vois juste
[Musique]
je n'ai qu'une fille laure c'est bien à
mort place la vie m'avait tout ce qu'on
m'a dit ma seule chance est nette
c'est toujours pour vous le dire on fait
de nos mères des martyrs
aujourd'hui face à lille et j'ai je
dresse - poing levé la tête aux
planteurs sans cesse à doubler d'efforts
la vie ne nous laisse pas le choix
toujours croire malgré nos repères de
différence il regarde l'espérance pour
que cet autre pour en finir une fois
qu'un mauvais souvenir
j'y crois
au regard de toutes ces femmes qu'on
juge et qu'on
messieurs parce que ça n'est jamais le
moment de regarder en face à la pression
et la peur
impossible d'écouter son coeur et le
rêve partant moussières sans jamais
pouvoir faire ma carrière je n'ai qu'une
philosophie c'est accepter car je vis
avec la force et le sourire ou pleurer
[Musique]
ne vous laisse pas de choix de l'enfant
ça
[Musique]
si ce projet
ce n'est pas tout
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous
alors que ma compagne
ça fait ma faim
le projet en preuve
pour que tous les
je vois parfois
sortez du premier casier où on y voit ma
casier
[Musique]
merci et bill imaginez vous à la base
pour la vie vous êtes les seuls en
france avant un concert
hahaha
m
cependant les avis et vous demandons
vraiment de bien faire attention aux
consignes sanitaires à savoir le port du
masque notamment fait s'il vous plaît
mais attention nous vous demandons s'il
est très généreux pour l'éditeur qui
vont passer devant vous tendrons la
manifestation mais aussi à la fin vous
savez que cette manifestation un coup et
on demande aussi à tous manutan m
restons connectés données sur le site de
la marge pour faire un don en ligne
ce que vous pouvez faire chez vous bien
sûr on rentre on également
les amis vous êtes très nombreux
j'aimerais aussi que nous puissions
salué la présence de monseigneur lebrun
archevêque de rouen
tu pourrais évolué merci merci à tous
des mecs qui sont en première ligne pour
le combat de la vie
[Applaudissements]
chers amis votre voix notre voie à toi
porter davantage auprès des politiques
chacun d'entre nous doit se sentir
engagé et interpeller les élus sur ces
sujets si important
il existe aujourd'hui un nouvel outil le
plateforme en ligne qui vous permet de
connaître la position de votre député
sur ces sujets et qui vous fournit des
outils pour l'interpeller il s'agit de
la plateforme éthique en veille éthique
en veille coin fr
alors que ceux qui sont chez eux sur le
zoom je vous demande de vous connecter
et fait du bruit sur internet
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de quoi avoir le
[Musique]
les projets
je
m
masson casseurs
et
[Musique]
le coup
il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aucune idée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la cabine
où
[Musique]
m
ce serait vu
[Musique]
on sourira
aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
d'ailleurs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai eu peur
m
vous les vols
kiki chambley
[Musique]
m
mais quoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous voulez
il
[Musique]
oh
auj
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
découvrant ce qui porte leur
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est la vie
les amis du vélo n'a jamais regardé
encore en vie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une
auj
on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pierre dalli s'est bien goupillé
la radicalité de ce soir qu'elle est là
2007 bilancielle part de la liberté ou
la mort c'est l'internet et irréversible
qui va quelques jours oui que les deux
trouvait à tout ce sur quoi ça servait à
[Musique]
la naissance des enfants
taher réunionnais car dans trois jours
amélie senna nouveau disque aux lois de
la déroute est un bon galio
excusez là la gestion ou la suppression
de la clause de conscience politique a
mis les personnels médical
[Musique]
oui cette proposition de loi mais la
persécution des quelques lignes de la
loi qui protège encore nous médecins
nous sommes nous envier aux auxiliaires
médicaux précisant que nul ne peut être
obligé de pratiquer un avortement ou d'y
concourir à quelques maillons de la
chaîne qu'ils se trouvent
[Musique]
la suppression vous êtes perdu
conscience voulue par conséquent
cimetière est lui-même en 1975
cette suppression est grave car cette
disposition législative mais mars est
même si elle n'est pas toujours rester
c'est vrai que le dernier refuge des
concerts rock qui va vous êtes club ne
change rien qu'il en existe déjà une
générale qui autorise un médecin a
retrouvé ses sens et que cela suffit
mais cet argument est fallacieux car en
vérité c'est celle du sort pour rien
dans le drame de l'avortement les droits
des actionnaires
les auxiliaires médicaux
[Musique]
savoir si le pouvoir d'obliger la nasa
métiers des secteurs de la conciergerie
cl - serviteur fend nabeul
[Musique]
bien et puis ça fait il vous est positif
les citoyens toi
[Musique]
voici les faits s'ils devaient le faire
nous voulons qu'elle soit souvent la
supériorité des sceaux lui de la nature
humaine
ils entendaient seulement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je fatigue mesure de respecter la ville
aux cent d'accueillir enfants et le
souci c'est celui qui l'a conduit
l'histoire de l'humanité avec ça on
s'active juin à l'exposition de volée à
la réduction sera là ou la belgique
voudraient une pièce physiquement le
meilleur numéro est un membre de la
semaine nous serons nous va retrouver
sous 3 6
[Applaudissements]
chères familles la descendre la clause
de conscience nous concerne tous chacun
d'entre nous doit servir votre liberté
devant la loi la liberté nous ont vécu
jusqu'au bien cette exigeante
antigone s'offre à maxime perez chouly
partir des commissaires tout bêtement
des fondeurs et qu'on pointe encore
maman mère vivait beaucoup ont perdu le
pouvoir et la corse à la base des
fièvres
ils sont les grands vainqueurs 15-9
transmis
[Applaudissements]
michael notamment s'il y allait facile
vous aussi des noirs et keith ablow
ariel jacobs ne soient vainqueurs se
demande le moral était utile at on
conscience est claire et elle apporte de
ferme bien ou des mélomanes
[Musique]
baveux nous avons comme une souris la
justice air comet
nous allons pouvoir temporel qu'il y ait
un avis de l autorité mais politiquement
[Applaudissements]
vous avez des solutions
si l'on compare les germes et la
victoire
nous sommes enfin une fierté et le
pouvoir des petits décembre à la dignité
des hommes qui sortent à l'inacceptable
carte la porte de 10 nous ne pouvons pas
nous avons tous lu pour réclamer l'
entière de la clause de conscience il
faut qu'on s'ouvre professionnels de
santé s'il pourrait rimer avec une
fausse plaque
nous défendrons envers et contre tout
l'inversé de notre motion
ou qu'ils honorent le titre car entre
nous et nos enfants et je ne veux y ait
des enfants souffrent en gare de tournus
ce pouvoir et cette limite et que votre
acuité au tee-shirt noir que nécessaire
mais ce que vous devez faire de
l'audience et non gardé confiance d'un
retour victoire finale certaines
familles ont reçu expliqué en juin en
force au passé donner le sang reçu
environ
on était générations à venir qui
désormais la tâche est immense et
regrette qu'aucun d'entre nous enverra
l'investissement mais nous avons laissé
si jamais des reculs une relance
nous avons la route de la vie qui doit
tenir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
on peut même d'autres pour les demandes
de toute manière
[Musique]
le
[Applaudissements]
notre manifestation
[Musique]
j'ai toujours
[Applaudissements]
je vais maintenant pour finir laisser la
main à notre gardien intervenants idée
élu au conseil régional ou de france
cette année selon l'association de
défense des actionnaires
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci à vous tous il parcourt cité
parvis des droits de l'homme
ce samedi der sar fort pour nous notre
humanité commençant dès la concession
[Musique]
merci à vous qui le rejoint par écran
interposé
depuis vous ville et vous vire merci à
tous ceux qui nous ont encouragés et
soutenus ils sont heureux et nous sommes
sortis à chaque parent sac qu'il y vient
chaque soutien aussi merci enfin à la
forme à la formidable et hilda
validation à tous
le super l'association partenaire tout
faris vie et le pays qu'ils ont permis
nécessaires à ses pieds le plus grand
événement au prix de france
[Applaudissements]
fondée il ya un sont déçus d'autant que
la mobilisation allait bientôt arriver
eh bien nous pourrons nous retrouver
dans la rue dans quinze jours avec nos
partenaires voir son enfant
nous devons également nous sommes ici et
penseur de la vie de la conception à la
mort naturelle
nous sommes dans la rue pour clamer que
toute vie mérite d'être vécue
[Musique]
et pourtant et pourtant en france
nous enregistrons un triste record celui
de tu ne sont remplis de 130 venir
avortements en jeu c'est en 2010 1
ce chiffre traduit un échec total
celui de notre politique de santé
publique en raison de la vague de
l'italie il y a deux fois moins
d'avortements depuis brisé sous gers
hérault plus grands succès notre souhait
des familles européennes
parmi les humains nous de notre côté
suisse nous on prend comme détruit de
réduire de moitié le nombre
d'avortements en france
c'est seulement maintenant mais pas un
acte médical
c'est une guerre pour les forces
japonaises
il a de lourdes conséquences physiques
et psychologiques
démographiques et écologiques pour notre
pays
le prophète tous les ans à 3 le nombre
divisé comme me le permettent les
propositions et pour je te vois bien
vite ressaisis et pour lesquels le
précédent moratoire complexifier les
raisons de notre audition pour nous
c'est clairement non
[Musique]
nous avons une première distinction
d'âge et c'est le devoir de la
commission de l'eau n'a pas été approuvé
en commission des affaires sociales au
sénat pour engranger le serveur je le
dis cela mais grandit si notre combat
politique c'est faire refroidir la même
s'ils demeurent qui s'est envolé le
sceau de 10,6 contre des shows
politiques
nous sommes une force jeunes déshérités
venus de tous les horizons et 20 88% et
concerts nous vous déçu qui permet de
nous comprend les kossi a même fortement
aidé leurs conséquences pour y remédier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
travaillez prenez parti et
parlementaires pour proposer deux mondes
une prévention de l'avortement six à
sept pour sièger pour nous parce que
l'avortement
les listes des idées ni un 9/10
parce qu'elle avait eu qui n'ont pas
fortement priorité de santé publique
et vite
[Applaudissements]
nous rendez vous début du vingt noeuds
quelques mois avant les élections
présidentielles
[Musique]
durant deux mois seulement
enfin nous pouvons
et puis en bouger les choses allaient ou
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le premier fera bientôt terminé
je ne sais vraiment pas si nous allons
regarder si la grande manifestation
surtout numéro
du coup nous sommes nous mêmes
[Applaudissements]
dans cette nuit et qui nous envahissent
nous attendons les vous vous êtes vous
confier ma vie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le mois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour
[Musique]
mais
vous
[Musique]
mais
il
[Musique]
oui
il se peut
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vidéo le plus bas de toute façon
merci à milan
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
people tenir dans ses parents l'attend
logistique nouvelle cible
[Musique]
courage les toits
[Applaudissements]
ok on sait ou zénith est selon lui
nécessaire en ces temps ci comme ça vous
merci je faisais le mien entré en cure
en effet marié brisé coli
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
il
[Musique]
comme ça
nous vous rappelons que vous pouvez
entrer chez vous à la foule le sol se
retrouve des roues minutes
vous pouvez revoir
[Musique]
voilà
fava
[Musique]
mais
oui
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
à voir
[Musique]
je
on
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
une
non
[Musique]
coc
une
[Musique]
pas nous
bush
[Musique]
le
ouah
[Musique]
il
et
[Musique]
m
toujours voulu voir à quoi c'est dû
[Musique]
[Musique]
à
je
[Musique]
parfois
c'est beau
[Musique]
je trouve
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
et
[Musique]
d
bon
[Musique]
tous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais
et
[Musique]
tous
les règles
[Musique]
et
il
[Musique]
quand même
santé
[Musique]
longtemps
non
je
[Musique]